Okay, now let me tell you where you're
going to get blown away. You thought
that detail was amazing. Okay?
Let me tell you where you're going to
get blown away.
Okay.
When Isaiah is writing,
he's writing
when Assyria is the superpower. The
Babylonians were nothing.
They were insignificant.
And yet Isaiah and Isaiah 39 to 55 says,
"Babylon is going to come to power and
dominance. Babylon is going to condemn
Judah and Jerusalem, and then God will
then
free
the Jews from Babylonian captivity by
raising up a king. And he tells them
what the name of the king is over 100
years before the king comes to power.
And then Isaiah records it in the book
so that when the Babylonians come to
power and when Cyrus comes, they will
have a written record proving, "Look,
our God mentioned you by name. Our God
said Babylon would dominate
even though when this was written it was
Assyria."
And then our God said you would come and
destroy the Babylonians and set us free.
He mentioned you by name.
All right?
Mentioned you by name. What do I mean?
Watch here.
Now, so you understand how amazing this
is. We're going to go through this.
Here, Isaiah 44:28, written in the 8th
century, 700s.
It is I who says of Cyrus, "He is my
shepherd." Cyrus did not even exist.
Cyrus conquered the Babylonians in 539
BC.
This is written in the 700s, 200 years
before Cyrus came to power, God already
mentioned his name, Koresh.
200 years later,
a king of Persia named Koresh comes and
destroys the Babylonians.
Skeptic, learn how to
write, brother. I know you're a troll.
Just take it easy.
You guys see it?
And Cyrus, being a Persian, would have
been have been a Zoroastrian. He would
have believed in multiple gods.
And so look what God says about Cyrus,
"And all my good pleasure he'll
complete, saying of Jerusalem it shall
be built, and of the temple your
foundation will be laid." Now, guys, if
you're not listening, you're going to
see why this is astonishing.
When
when God has Isaiah say this, the temple
was intact. Jerusalem wasn't destroyed.
But here God says, "When Cyrus comes to
power, he's going to tell you rebuild
Jerusalem and the temple."
Do you understand why this is like
mind-blowing?
When Isaiah is writing this, Jerusalem's
intact, the temple's intact, but
Isaiah's saying,
"Cyrus is going to come after the
Babylonians conquer, and he's going to
have you rebuild Jerusalem and the
temple." That only happened
200 years later, dude.
Did you know when the Babylonians
conquered Assyria? The Babylonians with
the Medes and Persians conquered
Assyria, Nineveh, in year 612 BC.
That's over 100 years after Isaiah wrote
this.
Now look what he goes on to say about
Cyrus. I don't know if a lot of us are
still here.
Isaiah 45:1-6 mentions him by name.
Thus says Yahweh to Cyrus his anointed.
Even calls him my anointed one, the one
I anoint to do what? My taken hold by
his right hand to subdue nations before
him, to loose the loins of kings, to
open doors before him so that gates will
not be shut. Now this is how I'm going
to empower him to conquer the kingdoms
and the Babylonians
and find their hidden treasures.
I will go before you and make the rough
places smooth. I'm going to make your
victories easy.
I will shatter the doors of bronze. Even
bronze doors won't stop you from coming
in. Cut through their iron bars. I will
give you the treasures of darkness,
meaning the hidden treasures
that no one knows where they are except
those who own those treasures.
And in the wealth of secret places, so
that you may know that it is I, Yahweh,
the God of Israel who calls you by your
name." Now I'm going to explain why he's
doing this. "For the sake of Jacob my
servant, I'm going to send you to send
Israel's back home, Israel."
Cuz during this time, they'll they'll
have been taken into captivity by the
Babylonians, but you're going to set
them free, send them back home.
"And Israel by my chosen one, I have
also called you by your name." Yep.
Cyrus came to power and destroyed the
Babylonians 539 BC. This is written 200
years before Cyrus came to power. So he
goes, "Look, I've already called you by
your name, mentioned your name, and had
Isaiah write it down."
"I've given you a title of honor, though
you have not known me." Here's the key.
Yep.
Here's the key.
God is already indicating because he's a
pagan, Zoroastrian, Persian, he's not
going to acknowledge me as the only true
God. He'll acknowledge that I'm a god,
but he'll think I'm one of many gods,
and I'm just the god of the Jews.
But I'm here to tell him,
"I am Yahweh, there is no other. Beside
me there is no god. I will gird you
though you have not known me. It's not
your god,
Ahura Mazda,
it's me
that they may know from the rising to
the setting of the sun that there's no
one beside me. I am Yahweh, there is no
other."
Do you understand what he's saying here?
Now, if you want proof that God has
desired the salvation of all peoples and
the pagan kingdoms,
why is God doing this? Note what he's
saying. I'm going to have Isaiah
announce
over 200 years of history, and the Jews
will preserve it as a record, so when
the Babylonians come to power, they will
show them, "Hey Babylon, you know who
gave you the victory? Our God. He said
you're going to come to power."
And then when I mention the name of
Cyrus before he's even born,
and he comes to power, you're going to
show Cyrus, "Look, our God mentioned you
by name, Koresh."
In order to give them infallible proof,
miraculous divine proof, "I am God,
their gods are nothing." In order then
to convince them to turn to me, believe
in me cuz I want to save them and bless
them.
That's why God is doing it.
Exactly, arcane.
I'm going to get there.
Do you understand?
Here you see the heart of God.
God is saying to Isaiah, "Write this
down because I want this to be a written
record
that I am the one who announced 200
years of history
to convince them and remove any doubt
that I am the only true God who created
the heavens and earth, who created all
the nations, who created them, and that
I love them and want them to be saved,
not just the Jews."
Give them written proof.
Cuz how you going to explain this away?
You understand what he's doing?
Yep, he did that with Nebuchadnezzar.
How you going to explain this away? Hey,
Cyrus, this book right here. Look, whose
name is there? My name.
This is written by our prophet Isaiah
200 years earlier.
He even said it wouldn't be the
Assyrians but the Babylonians that would
conquer them and you'd conquer the
Babylonians. Oh, really? Yeah. Do you
know why?
Why? Cuz he wants you to know he created
you, he created all the nations, he
created heaven and earth, he's the one
who allowed you to become dominant.
He's the one who helped you defeat your
enemies, not your Ahura Mazda, cuz he
created you to save you so you can know
him because he loves you, too.
Do you understand?
When's the last time you had anyone
unpack the book of Isaiah not only to
show you the miraculous supernatural
divine proof
of its of its inspiration, but that God,
even in the Old Testament, has gone out
of his way
to show that he loves all nations and
wants all nations to be saved, and he's
not a tribal god.
He's not just the god of the Jews.
You see?
That's the context of Isaiah 48. I'm
going to get back there in a minute.
Now we saw the Sennacherib cylinder,
right?
But guess what?
We also found
the Sennacherib prism. It's called
prism.
We also found the Cyrus cylinder.
Let me show you what the Cyrus cylinder
says.
I got to find it for you. And I'm going
to tie it in with Isaiah, and I'm going
to tie it in with Ezra and Chronicles.
Ready?
Extra-biblical confirmation of what we
find in the Bible.
So I had to give you See, this is what
book by book study looks like. Giving
you historical background, the cultural
background, so you understand the
significance.
Let me find It's called the Cyrus
cylinder.
That was the Sennacherib Sanhedrin
prism. Cyrus cylinder.
Let me find it.
Here's what it looks like.
They found it.
They found it from Cyrus.
There it is.
And in it, he issued a decree
saying that all the nations that the
Babylonians had conquered
are free to return to their homes,
restore their temples, and pray to the
god Marduk and their gods to bless him.
Marduk
Pray to Marduk
to bless me, and pray to your gods to
bless me for doing this favor to you.
Let's see. Let me find it.
I want to find the exact words.
And then I'm going to contrast it with
I'm going to contrast it with the Bible
says.
Let's see if I can find it.
There you go.
Marduk
Yep.
Without battle conflict, he conquered
them in a night. I am Cyrus, king of the
world, the great king, the powerful
king. And I'll get you the link in a
minute. Of Babylon, king of Sumer and
Akkad, king of the four quarters of the
world, son of Cambyses,
the great king, king of the city of
Anshan, grandson of Cyrus, the great
king, king of the city of Anshan, great
grandson of Teispes, the great king,
king of the city Anshan, a
eternal seed of royalty who's ruled Bel,
that's Baal, and Nebo love. Nebo That's
why the king was called Nebuchadnezzar.
Nebo was the name of their god.
And Marduk would have been Baal. In
whose administration, right? They
rejoice in their heart when I made my
triumphal entrance into Babylon.
I look I took up my lordly residence. By
the way, this is recorded in Daniel.
Daniel recorded
that Cyrus came in even without
right? Having to lift a sword, he
conquered the city because he caught
Belshazzar and his retinue drunk
in orgies,
caught unawares, unsuspected.
I took up my lordly residence. Go read
Daniel 5 and on. It's there in the book
of Daniel. Cuz he was there as an
eyewitness. Daniel saw this.
In the royal palace with the joy and
rejoicing,
Marduk, the great lord, moved the noble
heart of the residents of Babylon to me
while I gave daily attention to his
worship. My numerous troops marched
peacefully into Babylon. See? Conquered
without
having to lift a sword. In all Sumer and
Akkad, I permitted no enemy to enter.
The needs of Babylon and all of its
cities I gladly attended to. The people
of Babylon, the shameful yoke was
removed from them. See? I removed the
yoke of the Babylonians from them. And
what did he do? Their dwellings which
had fallen, I restored. I cleansed out
their ruins. See? He set them back to
restore their lands and their temples.
Right?
I restored, cleared out their ruins.
Marduk, the great lord, rejoiced in my
pious deeds and graciously blessed,
right? Me, Cyrus the king who worships
him, and Cambyses, my own son, all the
troops. Now watch. I'm going to get
there.
He mentions here Let me see here.
All the quarters of the earth from the
upper to the lower. Let me go here.
While we before him joyously praised his
exalted godhead, all the kings dwelling
in palaces of all the quarters of the
earth from the upper to the lower sea
dwelling, all the kings of the west land
dwelling in tents brought me their heavy
tribute. And in Babylon, kissed my feet
from
Ashur, that's Assyria, to Susa,
Akkad, Ashunnak, Zamban,
Maturnu, Deri, with the territory of the
land of Kutul,
cities on the other side. Now watch how
it's going to show you how accurate
Bible is of the Tigris, whose sites were
of ancient foundation.
The gods who resided in them, I brought
them back to their palaces. Here's the
key.
I sent the peoples to the lands of their
gods to go back, restore the temples of
their gods,
and start sacrificing to their gods.
Look.
I brought them back to their palaces,
caused them to dwell in a residence for
all time.
And the gods of Sumer and Akkad, whom
Nabonidus, to the anger of the lord of
the gods, had brought into Babylon. You
know what he's saying? When he took
their idols
to Babylon, I sent them back with their
idols.
By the command of Marduk. Marduk
commanded me to do so. You see why God
says, "Though you don't acknowledge me."
Now you're going to see how miraculously
accurate your Bible is. Why?
He gives credit to Marduk. He goes,
"Marduk gave me victory." Yahweh says,
"No, it was me, though you don't know
me."
See how miraculous your Bible is? I'm
going to get you the link in a minute.
I caused them to take up their dwelling
in residences that gladden the heart. I
sent them back with their idols that
Nabonidus had taken captive
because Marduk ordered me.
So they went back and brought into their
cities, prayed daily before Bel and
Nebo. Prayed to these gods for me, for
long life for me.
May they speak a gracious word for me
and say to Marduk, my lord, "May Cyrus
the king who worships you and Cambyses,
his son,
permit it all to dwell in peace." You
see it?
Okay.
Do you remember what God said?
"I, Cyrus, grab you by the hand.
I give you victory, but you don't
acknowledge it's me."
Are you telling me your Bible's not
supernatural? 200 years before Cyrus
came to power, God told you
by name who the king would be.
I'll tell you his name, it's Cyrus.
I'm the one who's going to fight for
him, but he won't acknowledge me. Look.
I opened the door. It wasn't your god
Marduk.
Your Marduk is nothing.
I'm the one who called you by name,
but you have not known me. You haven't
acknowledged that I'm the only god there
is.
Right?
You have not known me. Now remember he
mentioned Bel and Marduk?
Remember in the cylinder, he mentioned
Bel Marduk? Well, guess who God is going
to destroy and prove they're no gods.
Remember he said, "Pray to Bel and Nebo
Marduk."
Guess what God says. That's the very
reason why I'm doing this,
to show them Marduk, right?
Bel are no gods.
They are nothing. Here it is, black and
white, 200 years before this happened.
Bel has bowed down. Nebo stoops over. I
have destroyed your Bel, your Marduk,
your Nebo, to prove to you Babylonians
and you Persians, your gods are not
gods. They're nothing before me. Cuz
they're not the ones who announced this.
I did.
Did they tell you 200 years before
Babylon would come to power
when Assyria was a superpower? I don't
think so. Were they the ones who took
Jerusalem captive
and deported the Jews?
Did they tell you that before it
happened? I don't think so. Did they
tell you then Cyrus would come to power
and destroy the Babylonians?
Did they tell you that? I don't think
so. I did, and here's the record.
See it?
Are you not shocked
are you not shocked how Cyrus,
his cylinder and Sennacherib, his prism,
confirm what you read? And are you not
shocked that the very gods
that God condemned
and he was going to prove there are no
gods at all?
Bel and Nebo are the very gods that
Cyrus mentions in the cylinder?